hi this is chelsea clinton and i'm here
to give my opinion on some controversial
new york topics
[Music]
[Applause]
egg on a bagel every day what's your
go-to order because you have to have
salt pepper ketchup oh you know i really
just like salt and pepper i'm not a
ketchup kind of girl i admit
when harry met sally
cheese slice
central bark
ooh
i love every season in new york i can't
i can't make a choice on that one
even though like gross winter snow i i
mean my kids love the snow
like i i love new york in the winter
[Music]
that's really hard probably the chrysler
building
although my kids really like all the
different colors that light up the
empire state building but i love the
chrysler building i think it's such a
beautiful iconic piece of new york
oh
um
i think i have to play the fifth on that
one because my husband's a rabid
philadelphia
sports fan
[Music]
honey rusted nuts
thank you for having me drew and thank
you you for being new york
[Music]